okay so it's been how many years since
the series ended I think five that's
wild so then the movie comes around the
idea for the movie who calls who Jeff
calls you first you call Jeff what
happens yeah I've been very vocal about
wanting to bring it back on social media
every time I see Jeff I'm like let's
bring the show back
um but it had been a little while I kind
of let the the notion die uh and then
Jeff called me and immediately you know
he was like would you want to do a Teen
Wolf movie and I almost cut him off
before we finish saying the sentence I
was like absolutely please God yes I've
been like fantasizing about it and like
visualizing it sure yeah yeah I'm ready
I had like it was like really fat for a
while and then immediately when I ripped
my shirt off I had a six-pack again and
fangs started growing
um yeah I was so ready to do it I think
wanting this to happen for so long and
I've I've never let the character die
and the show die and I'm just always
it's so close to my heart I'm still
standing
don't feel the alpha
let me wake when it's going to die I saw
the article that they were gonna make a
Teen Wolf film
and I didn't think anything of it I just
thought oh that's so amazing I'm very
happy for everyone congratulations so I
text Jeff
congratulations and he said can I call
you
and I remember I was in this is this
park bench in New York and my my heart
like everything just sank and I kind of
like my my feet Stood Still and I said
yes and he called me and he asked he
said will you come back I want to bring
a house and back and immediately I said
yes and it was very very emotional for
us and um we kept in touch you know
since I left but he he's so so excited
about it that there's no way that I
could say no yeah speaking of Never
Letting characters die because Jeff had
said he was like I would only do a movie
if we brought Allison back that's wild I
know yeah he threatened us he threatened
us no he he actually asked her yeah
and and we're like he's like would you
be interested you know he wasn't like
please you know it was just a simple
question and there's something a very
simple Yes an emphatic yes please how do
I know she's really Alice who are you
it's me and Scott
it's Caillou
what does it mean for Scott to
potentially you know he sees the first
love of his life loaded question I know
it's a lot because you know it's been 15
years
um more than it's been like 18 since
Allison's died yeah you know grieving
never really ends the morning process
never ends but you you cope and you
accept and you move on and
um you know Scott's at a point when we
see him that he is lonely and he's
reminiscing and wistful and misses the
past and but you know obviously he's
gonna have to move on he can't this is
not he has to if he wants to continue
with his life and find a new family and
blah blah blah
um it can't be Allison because she's
gone and so he's accepted that and then
he sees her and there's just like I
don't know how to feel am I is she still
15 is it illegal for me to like her now
you know it's like there's all these
flooded emotions and mixed feelings
about it all but you know she's always
has been his true love and and has been
since the beginning of Teen Wolf and
um it's just it's gonna be a weird ride
for Scott to kind of
you know figure it out and then there's
all these other weird scenarios that
kind of get in the way of them and it's
it's a wild wild wild ride and then for
Tyler and Crystal what did it feel like
to just reunite after all this time on a
Teen Wolf set it was awesome it was
awesome yeah that was one of the things
where because like I
I had worked with you since uh I don't
know to a long time I can't remember how
long yeah but um that was everything
about filming this movie was so
nostalgic the crew was the same everyone
else was still like all the actors were
the same but then seeing crystal in
Atlanta I was just like where the hell
am I right now and it was so it just
felt so good and like you know it was
nice because last time I saw you we when
we worked together I was 23.
and I'm 30 and so it just felt good to
as a 30 year old to come back into this
and and you know reconnect and get to
know each other again and you know it's
it's different yeah and the very last
scene we actually filmed together was
her death scene have you re gone back
and re-watched that scene yes
foreign
[Music]
what is that like it never gets easy
really never ever gets easy it was
tricky for me because for that scene I
researched had to research I didn't have
to but I have this
obsession with having everything be real
so I had to research what it actually
happens to your body when you die so I
was trying really hard in that scene to
figure out her physicality and what like
what's shutting down in her body and
what does that feel like but then I
remember on the day I just let go and I
just felt so much love and I think that
comes through in the scene where she's
she says she loves him and
um it's very emotionally charged
[Music]
I love you
yeah
sorry I was gonna say when you in the
research you also ex you know evacuate
your bowels you do and she even did that
on Saturday I know that's a joke
[Laughter]
sorry I had to
I'm still a 23 year old I love it
so where do we pick things up where do
we find your characters all this time
has passed where are we we were much
older because it's about how many years
it's been well so we were much older
than our characters ending high school
at the end of the show but then we we
fast forward 15 years where we're
actually either our age and with some of
the actors they went from playing High
School to actually older than that than
what they actually are
um on screen for this movie and your
character has a cool job yes yes that we
get to see that was so fun to see
Lydia being a professional so uh yeah
Lydia is no longer in Beacon Hills along
with some of the other
characters and then some of us did stay
behind and beefing up Beacon Hills but
then they needed extra beef to come and
fight some stuff and Malia is stoked
about that she'd missed the pack so you
have your podcast holler back now yeah
where you go back and you kind of relive
the episodes how in doing that what has
been like the biggest memory that has
been dressed up from your time on T wolf
oh gosh I love doing this podcast
because I talk way too much
unfortunately and I love asking bizarre
questions I love games
um like icebreakers in school are my
favorite thing so I guess revisiting I
think Jeff's history as a writer
fascinated me in fact just fascinated me
in that
um I really got to take him through
pre-teen wolf and what led to Teen Wolf
was was pretty fun when's the last time
you've rewatched Teen Wolf or have you
re-watched it at all I haven't I I
really
um I'm too scared it was such like I
don't like watching myself on camera
thing or is it like the the feelings you
know I just wanted to live as the
experience that it was for me I just
felt so loved in that in this family and
I I mean that it just was such a
positive
and we we do we do we do conventions we
we just did the movies so like I don't
know I just feel like revisiting it
almost be too much like I it's too much
love I I don't want to love bomb Myself
by re-watching
Teen Wolf again I hadn't re-watched only
because when you re-watch something
you've already lived it once so to go
back and live it again you're like oh I
had to take my dog to the vet that day
and you're my head's not really in
I I view it from the eyes of the initial
viewer which was me just living it and
so um
that's where it gets murky for me
personally but but it's been fun to
re-watch it through the podcast because
of
having to re-watch it from a different
forcing myself from a to a different
perspective is there something that you
wish somebody told you like that when
you first came on to Teen Wolf I don't
think they can prep you I was just in
Brazil with Colton and I've been on
stages before where there's you know
thousands of people whether it had been
I was Miss Teen USA so like I competed
like on live television I gave speeches
and but when Colton and I came out on
the stage at the Brazil Comic-Con a
couple months ago you could see it in
our faces it's it's it's like we we
we're like this
it's like it's like our first time you
know in Hollywood in that moment it's
like it came back and you're just like
wow I I almost forgot how big this show
is and now hopefully the movie but um
yeah because of the fans and they were
there and you felt it and it was
extremely overwhelming yeah but you've
been on the show since season one so
yeah the whole world feels like a block
party is what I say and I know that's
not normal
um and it's a privilege to be able to go
to another con and be like oh people
know you hear this is strange
um but I would say if I could go back
and give myself advice or any gen zero
on a hit show I think I would say I was
so nervous
um and I would just not worry about the
future and really enjoy that moment I
think that's the biggest advice I would
give you know wolf pack is also coming
out and I've been talking to this young
Cass and they were just talking about
it's like you know we were at Comic Con
all this stuff and I was thinking about
you guys like that first year that
you're doing Teen Wolf and it's like
suspense the the hype is building like
when you think back on that
yeah oh I got the chills too yeah
there's a lot tied to that there is it
was very exciting you could feel it was
literally Electric in the air you know
just just that whole first year we were
going to New York we were traveling we
went to Brazil we literally traveled all
over the world spreading the word of
Teen Wolf and the hype kept growing more
and more every time we went somewhere
yeah yeah I'm getting the chills right
now I know and it was intense it was a
it was it was a fun thing for all of us
to do together and yeah the energy was
just it was really like there's this is
about to be huge yeah is there anything
you wish somebody told you back then I
wish someone would have told me to
really take it in
because I think I did to a certain
extent but it was also new I we hadn't I
hadn't experienced anything like it I
don't think anyone really knew
what the success of the show was going
to be so there was like this I don't
know I think I got caught up in the in
the Whirlwind of it all and I wish that
somebody would have like said pay
attention this is going to be something
you have forever when you're thinking
about a movie and from a show it's
usually like oh there's all these
seasons and we do the movie and that is
it is this it or are you ready to rip
your shirt back off hell yeah dude I'm I
never want this show to die this movie
to die now you know I I want there to be
more I don't know what capacity
um I want more I've always wanted it and
uh you know I think the fans do too yeah
hopefully they'll still want some more
after they watch this movie and and
we'll go from there but yeah I'm I'm 100
ready to be geriatric wolf always
[Music]